our main story tonight I'd like to do
something a little different and just
quickly tell you about a beloved icon of
my childhood and it's this man for 20
years he made the dreams of young people
come true with his hugely popular Jim'll
Fix a program best known for his
trademark jewellery Traxxas tinted
glasses and to ban a cigar now I know
it's hard to believe but that
bizarre-looking man Jimmy Savile was a
national hero
we named places for him we gave him a
knighthood we even put up this statue of
him even though it clearly looks more
like a cheese sculpture of George Carlin
that someone left in the Sun now he had
a show called jimil fixing where he
basically granted wishes and like many
British kids I actually wrote to him I
asked him to make me the mascot for
Liverpool Football Club and he never
wrote back which I'm actually glad about
because after he died Britain began to
find out who he really was
and the truth was horrific he's gone
from a much-loved entertainer and
respected charity fundraiser to a man
described by Scotland Yard as a
predatory sex offender Jimmy Savile
headstone was here for less than three
weeks his epitaph read it was good while
it lasted oh that is an unsettling thing
to have written on his gravestone
although to be fair nearly every famous
epitaph would sound horrifying written
on a sex-offenders gravestone from Dean
Martin's everybody loves somebody
sometime to Rodney Dangerfield there
goes the neighborhood
yeah funny funny but if he'd been a sex
offender not so much
the point is Sal's headstone was taken
down as was that sign and that creepy
statue because once we found out that he
was a monster we accepted it was no
longer appropriate to publicly glorify
him which actually brings us to our main
story tonight the Confederacy America's
tracksuit sex offender now in recent
years there has been a robust debate
over Confederate symbols from Flags
being taken down two statues being
removed to the white nationalist rallies
in Charlottesville both the one that
ended in violence in August and another
one that happens just last night so as
this debate is clearly not going away we
wanted to take a look at some of the
arguments because you don't have to look
hard to find people very upset at the
idea of Confederate statues being taken
you can't change history you can't pick
and choose what you decide is history
like yeah I'll just leave them alone and
leave more they are you know they're
part of history I just don't think we
can erase our history it may not
represent the best idea that anybody
ever came up with but nevertheless it's
part of our history and I think it
should stay there
you know I'll give him this he's right
that the Confederacy and everything that
came with it is to put it mildly not the
best idea
anybody ever came up with because that
of course is making grilled cheese on a
toaster turned sideways that is a
billion dollar idea that is also
completely worthless but they're also
right about one thing we should remember
our history so tonight let's do that and
let's look at the unique heritage of
these symbols starting with the fact
that there are a lot more than you might
expect the Southern Poverty Law Center
found some 1500 Confederate memorials
across the country more than 700 of them
are statues and monuments and ten US
military bases are named for Confederate
officers think about that there are US
military bases named for Confederate
officers and they were the enemy they
killed US soldiers
that's what finding out that Nancy
Kerrigan named her child Tonya Harding
why would you do that
that's a weird choice and tributes to
the Confederacy are everywhere in the
south and notably some in the north too
and that map doesn't include kitschy
ways that the Civil War is presented
like at this family restaurant Dolly
Parton's Dixie Stampede brings a
rip-roaring taste of America to life
Dixie stamp
it is a musical extravaganza of sight
and sound centered around our friendly
north south rivalry
friendly servers bring the delicious
warhorse feast right to you including a
whole rotisserie chicken and all the
Pepsi iced tea or coffee you like yes
that is a Confederate soldier serving a
small child all the Pepsi she likes
which is still remarkably only Pepsi
second-worst ad campaign with
experiences like that it can seem like
the Civil War is just a friendly rivalry
a fun colorful part of US history but
that admits the key fact about the Civil
War the Confederacy was fighting for the
preservation of slavery and that's not
my opinion that is just a fact there are
many ways that we know this slavery is
mentioned in multiple states
declarations of secession with
Mississippi saying our position is
thoroughly identified with the
institution of slavery the Confederate
Constitution contains a clause
enshrining slavery forever and then
there's the speech Alexander Stevens the
Confederate vice president gave in 1861
in which he articulated the basic
principles for the Confederate nation
its foundations are laid its cornerstone
rests upon the great truth that the
Negro is not equal to the white man that
slavery subordination to the superior
race is his natural and normal condition
Wow subordination to the superior race
that is explicit if the Confederacy was
not about slavery somebody should really
go back in time and tell the
Confederacy that
and yet remarkably many people think the
civil war was over something else when
people were asked what do they think the
main cause of the civil war is 48
percent said mainly about states rights
only 38% said mainly about slavery 9%
said both and that is amazing only 38%
thought the civil war was mainly about
slavery in other words look tear left
now look to your right statistically all
three of you live in a country where
only 38% of people think the civil war
was mainly about slavery and on that
states rights argument for the record
the southern states were ardently Pro
states rights but with some glaring
exceptions notably when northern states
passed laws to help protect runaway
slaves the South wanted the federal
government to override those state's
laws so they loved states rights as long
as they as they were the right states
rights the wrong states rights would be
states wrongs wrongs which would need to
be righted by the right states rights
look to put it really simply they just
wanted to run black people and they
didn't much care how that's a fact and
but that's a very hard fact for some
people to accept especially if a member
of your family fought for the
Confederacy and sometimes the
understandable desire to want a distance
your relative from that cause can lead
to people distorting the cause itself
just watch as one man at a community
meeting in North Carolina defended a
Confederate statue by talking about his
family history my great-grandfather was
a Confederate soldier and I was proud of
that because my opinion of his fight was
for his rights I don't know what his
rights were I wasn't there he was dead
long before I came along but I'm really
concerned about our Monument I want it
to stay it reminds me that I got a
little rebel in me you know we all want
to kind of be independent we all have a
little rebel in us even the ladies
ladies hashtag feminism hashtag
Confederacy I don't know why his
great-grandfather fought it is hard to
know the motivations of any individual
soldier what we do know is that again
collectively they were fighting to
preserve the institution of slavery and
I do get honestly I honestly kicked
wanting a more comfortable history for
your family but in doing so you can't
invent a more comfortable history for
your country because you'll be erasing
the actual painful experiences of many
Americans as a fellow North Carolinian
explains when I walk by this statue
actually becomes very painful when I
think of the suffering that my ancestors
were through these enslaved people abuse
people for their own economic impact and
it should not be celebrated by these
statutes right and that is the harsh
reality of what was done by those
Confederate men and yes even the ladies
hashtag Confederacy if you want to see a
perfect crystallization of what happens
when two people have wildly different
views of the same symbol
just watch this local news clip why do
you carry the flag because this is my
heritage my family fought to save their
form under this flag who was working
that fall that is a good tough question
and the news clip actually cut out there
but we were so intrigued to find out
what his response was we tracked it down
and whatever you are expecting you're
going to be surprised
who was working that fall who was
working the favor do you know how much a
slave cost back in you know you are in
the wrong when you decide your best
argument is screaming at a black man do
you know how expensive you used to be it
is these comments like that one that
landed this guy on the cover of holy
that is not remotely the point
magazine and look that that is clearly
an intense example but denial of this
painful part of history can take many
forms look at PBS is finding your roots
where Henry Louis Gates explores
celebrities family histories and he
often finds some famously Ben
Affleck pulled strings to get the show
to remove all references to his
slave-owning ancestors and though he
later apologized that impulse right
there is not good because it sanitizes
history and while there is no easy way
to respond to learning that kind of
horrible information it is worth
watching Anderson Cooper find out how
one relative of his died Boykin was
murdered by a rebellious slave wow your
ancestor was beaten to death with a farm
home god that's amazing
this isn't over I'm blown away you think
it deserved ya not to live a life that
could lead a descendant of yours to one
day say a guy's master grandpuppies head
in with a garden hoe that's amazing
great job that guy but my absolute
favorite response to a nasty surprise
undoubtedly comes from Larry David who
received a real one-two punch are you
telling me that my great-grandfather
fought for the south in the Civil War
what are you kidding oh my goodness I
hope no slaves show up on this please
turn the page
now Larry this is another part of the
8th
[Laughter]
boy that's unbelievable oh boy oh boy
yeah pretty pretty pretty bad Larry
David is not responsible for what his
ancestors did none of us are I have to
believe that because I'm English and I
would like to go to an Indian restaurant
again at some point in my life but but
we do have to reckon personally and as a
country with what our heritage means you
can't ignore it like Batman you can't
say it's something else like Town
Meeting Santa
you've got to actively painfully come to
grips with slavery and the lasting
benefits and disadvantages that it
conferred in ways that frankly we
haven't yet and that actually brings us
back to Confederate monuments because
there is something about them that
symbolizes our reluctance to have that
conversation and that is the dates that
they went up because while some initial
memorials were built mainly in
cemeteries shortly after the Civil War
the real surge came much much later the
Southern Poverty Law Center says a
majority of the more than 700
Confederate monuments in public spaces
across the country were erected decades
after General Lee's surrender it's true
as this chart of the years that they
were dedicated shows there was a big
spike from 1900 to 1920 as white
southerners were reasserting their
dominance through things like Jim Crow
laws with another spike in the 50s and
60s as the civil rights movement was
gaining steam so those statues weren't
so much commemorating recently fallen
dead as sending a pretty hostile message
to African Americans and sending
messages is kind of what statues are
often for this one says we love freedom
this one says the most notable thing
about our city is a fictional character
and this one says about yay big
we still don't know what he was trying
to measure but whatever it was it was
about yay big but not for some
Confederate statutes though for some
Confederate statutes the intent is
crystal clear in that town meeting from
before the statue that they were
debating it was this one which went up
in 1914 and a leader of that County's
chapter of the KKK gave a speech at its
dedication calling the occasion and
opportunity to recall the achievements
of the great and good of our own race
and blood which again is pretty on the
nose right there and the largest
confederate memorial the carving on
Stone Mountain in Georgia is located
where the 20th century KKK was born it
depicts three Confederate leaders on
horseback and it was completed in 1972
so that means there is color footage of
the dedication after nearly half a
century of work the memorial carving
here at Stone Mountain is finally
finished and officials are calling it
the eighth wonder of the world we must
recall those principles of loyalty
dignity and honor that shine through the
lives of men we can commemorate today
yes that was vice president Spiro Agnew
commemorating the loyalty of literal
traitors but what can you really expect
from a man whose name rearranged spells
grow a penis some monuments went up even
more recently oh I want to show you one
that was erected on private lands but
very much for public consumption because
once you see it you will not forget it
the statue was erected in 1998 it
portrays Nathan Bedford Forrest on his
horse gun in one hand and sword in the
other surrounded by Confederate State
battle flags visible for all to see on
the side of i65
Forrest was a Confederate General and an
early leader of the KKK that is just
objectively terrifying regardless of
context he looks like if a nickel did
cocaine so so some of these statues
commemorate people who fought a war to
preserve slavery were erected to assert
white supremacy and were dedicated by
Klan members and yet there is a blanket
defense that tends to get offered by
people and not just people also this guy
they're trying to take away our culture
they're trying to take away our history
okay so that argument is taking these
statues down obliterates history which
is clearly just ridiculous first
monuments are not how we record history
books our museums are Ken Burns twelve
part miniseries our statues are how we
glorify people or in the case of one in
Tokyo how we glorify giant radioactive
lizards and yet the president's concern
seems to be that tearing down statues
leads to a slippery slope this week it's
robert e lee i noticed that stonewall
jackson's coming down i wonder is it
George Washington next week and is the
Thomas Jefferson the week after you know
you really do have to ask yourself where
does it stop okay well I'll tell you
where it stops somewhere anytime someone
asks where does it stop the answer is
always somewhere you might let
your kid have Twizzlers but not inject
black tar heroin you know you don't just
go well after the Twizzlers where does
it stop and the same is true of
Confederate monuments think of it this
way all people living and dead exist on
what I'm gonna call the Hitler hanks
spectrum from bad to good and at some
points on the spectrum monuments to
honor people are going to be
inappropriate although to be fair it
does get tricky around the middle where
of course you'll find a dove handler
there are clearly people deserving of
statues who are imperfect humans and
sometimes our standards change over time
which can then get tricky because you're
judging historical figures by modern
standards but for many Confederate
monuments especially those erected well
after the Civil War valorising the cause
or leadership of the Confederacy this
really isn't a close call this is your
babysitters showing up in a jimmy savile
t-shirt I don't care what you think that
represents you're not staying home with
my kid tonight and for robert e
lee in particular it's actually even
easier because of this interestingly
robert e lee was once asked about
placing memorials at gettysburg in 1869
the former general replied i think it
wiser not to keep open the sores of war
but to follow the examples of those
nations who endeavoured to obliterate
the marks of civil strife to commit to
oblivion the feelings engendered it's
true robert e lee was opposed to statues
of people like robert e lee so any city
that decides to keep a statue of him
should at the very least at a speech
bubble saying you know i told you all
specifically not to do this so so what
do we do now what what i would argue
that nothing is not acceptable and and
trying to paper over the cracks can
actually make things worse in the 1990s
Richmonds tried to fix its Monument
Avenue a streets lined with statues of
Confederate leaders by adding African
American tennis legend Arthur Ashe to it
and you can't just give Confederates a
black friend and say we're good right
we're good Arthur's up there you love
Arthur so so if we really want to learn
from and honor our history perhaps the
first step might be to put most of these
statues somewhere more appropriate
surrounded by ample historical context
like in a museum where people go to
proactively learn about history and also
to punish their children and please try
not to think of this as a loss because
it's actually a real opportunity and
I'll show you please come with me
because if a when a plinth becomes empty
that is actually a huge chance for your
area to honor someone who really
deserves it
and I have some some ideas for
replacements that I would love to run by
you first
Beaufort County South Carolina how about
a giant statue of Robert smalls here he
was born into slavery he stole a
Confederate boat and he sailed it to
freedom and later served five terms in
Congress this guy is amazing Atlanta
Texas you are the birthplace to Bessie
Coleman the first
woman pilots why would you not want this
in your talents is incredible now
Florida you might not want an individual
but how about something that honors what
your state represents something that
says you've got a little rebel in you so
I give you this statue of your official
state reptile an alligator giving
everyone the finger
he's called Herman and he definitely
says Florida while also having nothing
to do with slavery and finally finally
there is Charleston and to you I say
this why have a divisive Confederate
statue when instead that pedestal can be
filled by your favorite son the actual
student
Charleston Charleston Charleston is the
site of the first free public library in
America it's fascinating Steven every
year we host zagoon row fests the
southeast most comprehensive migration
focused birding festival that sounds
incredible oh google it
see Charleston you can have this 24
hours a day seven days a week and I
actually I need to do my show five days
a week five how Oh
we're also traveling Leisure's number
one us destination for the last five
years running come on Justin
[Applause]